five minutes I hope it's not a hybrid
Wow look who it is
hey come on what are you doing I'm
waiting for my car here it is
hop in I just detailed this puppy yeah
yeah got a new air freshener just for
you yeah smells like them all yeah why
are you my driver
oh it's queer love marketing you know
they thought this was the most efficient
way to get the word out about our movie
go through the big six how kidding you
already know about it okay well yeah at
least you don't got to do morning radio
this is new admits about making a movie
didn't pay to nap in the trailer
immediate feedback on my personality are
you no rush I am alright we all I want
to be a father but I think I'd be better
the cool uncle you know what I mean he
wears no fancy doesn't the face when he
doesn't have a job nobody cares you so
cool yet slightly misunderstood uncle
you doing bitch what's going on no these
are just my unscripted thoughts on
family dynamics you know cool uncle you
go to him if you need a condom see
that's what I'm talking about
whoo what kind speaking of driving you
know what drives me batty is when my mom
calls and she's like hey it's mom
yes I know who you are I recognize your
voice from yelling at me to move out of
the basement this way doing trapping
people and forcing your comedy on them
no just like you know really cool
comedians whose opinions I value oh this
guy knows what I'm talking about
all right guys there's no guy what else
is going on Oh what are we doing why
aren't we moving
oh I'm completely out of gas air
conditioners hair conditioners sound the
same but they're totally different no
one's like turn on the air conditioner
central to four four out of Watts ten
five four you know makes a funny word
right like you can say something mint
condition but I don't mean it smells
good
that's a keeper is it fine then wait we
having the sex again yeah I'm just not
that kind of girl I only have sex once
on the first date I'm just gonna
over your traveled the race to the de
patatas path what you learn by Oh club
I've been telling you something by I've
been dating this girl she's white a
white girl he does look like you and
young white girls okay we hate eros oh I
know that could be I'm getting a too
young single Pakistani woman this is the
breeder for your science your exile
that's your favorite show Hannah the
truth is out there are you judging
Pakistan Next Topmodel know how we have
arrangement I didn't I call to do good
can you imagine a world in which we end
up I'm looking for Emily Gardner she was
checked in tonight there's an infection
we put her in a medically induced coma
coma you should call a fan thank you
come on we're gonna handle things from
here I think I'm just gonna wait
anywhere
broke up I'm not sure why you're here
it's just a for a second with this seat
is that lady still looking at me so 9/11
of all we wanted to have a conversation
with people you've never talked to
people about 9/11 do anything you gotta
call the games now I get play you can't
run it you try to plan it word and
nobody can run okay and then Allen henge
can see you would one get screwed up
with your daughter
yeah
[Music]
they give you some advice come out love
isn't easy that's why they call them up
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't have to get to him I thought I
could just talk saying something
something small would come out